Générique
...
Musique hip-hop
-Certains seront peut-être
les aviateurs de demain.
Ils ont entre 13 et 18 ans
et sont mordus d'aviation.
Ces adolescents font partie
des Escadrilles Air Jeunesse,
un programme immersif
de l'Armée de l'air et de l'espace.
Pendant plusieurs semaines,
le Journal de la Défense
a suivi Tom...
Alix...
Manon...
et Rayan.
Des jeunes qui, au fil des mois,
vont confirmer
une vocation naissante
et prendre leur envol.
Ryan en rêvait :
voler à bord du Piper L-4H,
un avion militaire
utilisé par l'US Army
sur tous les fronts
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
et lors du débarquement
de juin 44.
Un rêve devenu réalité,
grâce à son escadrille.
-Beaucoup de sensations
dessus...
Et puis on peut voir
qu'un avion des années 40,
quand même,
c'est incroyable de le voir
restauré ainsi
et voler dedans,
c'est un privilège.
-On les surnomme
"les équipiers EAJ".
Comme Ryan, ils sont 700
à vivre
cette expérience unique.
Répartis sur le territoire
national...
en Outre-mer et à Djibouti.
Pour eux, l'année est ponctuée
de rendez-vous sportifs
et culturels,
à la découverte
du monde de l'aéronautique.
L'Armée de l'air et de l'espace
s'est inspirée
du modèle anglais des cadets
de la Royal Air Force.
Objectif : étoffer la passion
de ces adolescents
avec en toile de fond,
un soupçon de cadre militaire.
-A mon commandement,
garde à vous !
Fixe !
A droite... Droite.
-Ryan a intégré le dispositif
en avril dernier,
année de création
de l'EAJ d'Angers.
-Je me suis retrouvé équipier
grâce à mon collège.
Il y avait des pancartes,
on va dire, des petits flyers,
où il y avait marqué
que les Escadrilles Air Jeunesse
ouvraient à Angers.
C'était par l'armée de l'air.
Ca m'avait intéressé,
vu que j'aime les avions
depuis tout petit.
Découvrir l'armée de l'Air avec ça,
ça me passionnait.
Je me disais que ça allait être
une superbe expérience.
Du coup, j'ai postulé
et puis j'ai été pris.
-Ryan n'a que 13 ans et demi
et se familiarise déjà
avec le garde à vous.
Il prend doucement ses marques,
encadré
par le capitaine Christophe.
-La militarité,
elle reste à bas bruit.
On leur fait pas un stage
de garde à vous-repos
pendant trois jours
et forcément à cet âge-là,
quand la semaine, ils parlent :
"Monsieur..."
Et quand ils arrivent ici,
c'est difficile de se recoordonner
pour mon capitaine.
-Christophe a plus de 35 ans
d'armée à son actif.
Après avoir gravi les échelons,
il a terminé sa carrière
comme formateur au CPA 10,
une unité
des forces spéciales.
Aujourd'hui réserviste
opérationnel,
c'est lui qui donne
le tempo à Angers.
-Ce qui m'a surpris
la 1re fois,
c'est la volonté d'engagement,
la passion de ces gamins
pour l'aéronautique.
Alors, pas uniquement
de l'aéronautique militaire,
mais tout ce qui touche
à l'aéronautique,
ils sont très calés.
On leur apporte,
parce qu'on a un référentiel
via l'histoire de l'aéronautique
et de l'armée de l'Air,
des jalons importants
pour étoffer cette connaissance.
-Supervisés par la direction
des ressources humaines
de l'Armée
de l'air et de l'espace,
le Centre d'études stratégiques
aérospatiales
et l'Ecole de l'air et de l'espace,
les EAJ ont un programme commun.
-On a quand même un cap,
une sorte de bible,
si vous me permettez,
qui nous permet de savoir,
où on voit
quelles sont les matières,
le timing qu'on doit faire.
On essaie de respecter ça
mais chaque EAJ a son terroir
et c'est pas toujours facile.
-A Angers, il n'y a pas
de base aérienne.
L'EAJ a donc noué
un partenariat
avec l'Espace Air Passion,
premier musée
d'aviation légère, civile
et militaire de France.
Un mercredi sur deux,
ces équipiers
rencontrent
des bénévoles passionnés,
comme Dominique,
ancien officier à la retraite.
-Lorsque nous avons été
sollicités,
nous avons été très vite
conquis par ce projet,
avec la spécificité
du patrimoine aéronautique,
sachant qu'il y a des matières,
si je puis m'exprimer ainsi,
socles, mais il y a également
des matières optionnelles,
et cette présentation
du patrimoine,
comment on restaure
un appareil,
la partie documentation,
la partie menuiserie,
mécanique, électricité
et ensuite, aussi, maintenance,
pour ensuite
perpétuer la remise en vol
de ces avions.
C'est un grand bonheur,
parce que,
tout petit déjà,
j'étais passionné d'avions.
Et puis, c'est vrai
que si on veut
laisser une trace,
il faut transmettre.
-Bon, en colonne par un,
on va s'approcher,
parce que l'idée
de la manoeuvre,
c'est de remonter ce bel objet.
-Cette année,
Ryan a participé
avec son escadrille
à la rénovation du Breguet 904,
un planeur construit
dans les années 60.
-Il faut bien qu'il y ait
des personnes qui tiennent,
mais surtout pas
par les volets,
uniquement
par les parties fixes.
Pour empêcher de basculer,
c'est surtout ici,
et puis la partie
supérieure ici.
-Ca ?
-Oui.
-Et ce mercredi,
c'est l'heure
de l'assemblage final.
Il faut porter
des ailes de 10 mètres
pour les accrocher
au fuselage de l'avion.
Une opération délicate.
-C'est parti.
-On y va ?
-1, 2, 3 !
-On doit montrer aux jeunes
comment on fait
pour garder le suivi
de cette machine.
La mise en croix,
le contrôle des gouvernes...
Tout ce qui est donné
par le constructeur,
auquel on reste très rigoureux
comme autrefois.
J'ai toujours rêvé
de montrer
ce que je savais faire.
Je l'ai dans la peau
et je le garde jusqu'à la fin.
-Le bord d'attaque, toujours.
-Mais il faut plus de...
-Non, elle est pas totalement mise.
-Elle est pas mise ?
-Lève encore un petit peu.
Musique douce
...
-Il faut baisser.
-Baissez un petit peu.
-Baissez doucement.
...
-Direction Evreux,
où l'une des toutes premières
escadrilles
a été créée en 2019,
sur la base aérienne 105.
Ce mercredi, ces équipiers
se déplacent en ordre serré
pour la première fois,
et se coordonner
comme des militaires,
cela ne s'improvise pas.
-Il faut venir comme vous le faites,
en cassant le rang.
Il faut une première rangée.
Vous êtes en ordre décroissant.
Il faut les plus petits devant,
vous vérifierez
vos alignements après
et on va vous donner
les instructions.
Colonne !
Première colonne !
En colonne ! Tu suis !
Tu suis en colonne !
Des colonnes !
-Encore, encore...
Stop !
-Que le coude gauche,
et vraiment tordu comme ça !
-Allons enfants
-DE LA PATRIE
LE JOUR DE GLOIRE...
-C'est impressionnant.
C'est impressionnant
de se déplacer
avec beaucoup de monde,
mais comme si on était qu'un,
je sais pas comment le dire.
Mais c'est impressionnant.
On a tous le même pas,
et la même forme, surtout.
-Alix a 15 ans.
Depuis un an, il est membre
de l'EAJ d'Evreux.
A sa tête, la commandant Laurence,
réserviste opérationnelle.
Cette professeure
d'histoire-géographie n'a pas hésité
à s'engager dans l'encadrement
de 55 équipiers.
-J'ai une passion
pour l'aéronautique
depuis toute petite.
Quand je vois un avion décoller,
j'ai le coeur
qui bat la chamade.
Je pense que même mon rêve
le plus intime,
c'est de passer
mon brevet de pilote.
L'aéronautique, plus l'enseignement,
la transmission,
Escadrilles Air Jeunesse,
ça a fait tilt.
On est là pour faciliter,
pour que ces rêves se réalisent
ou en tout cas
montrer la voie.
On est comme une sorte de fenêtre,
un petit peu,
sur tout le monde
aéronautique.
-Parmi ces jeunes, nombreux
convoitent un poste
dans les métiers
de l'aéronautique.
Pour certains, l'avenir
se dessine déjà dans les airs.
C'est le cas d'Alix,
mais aussi de Tom,
17 ans.
Sur le tarmac,
leur escadrille
rencontre un pilote
chevronné de CASA,
un avion de transport
militaire.
-Sur la plupart
des avions militaires,
il y a cette disposition.
C'est juste pour des raisons
de praticité.
Vous vous rendez compte
que pour charger
ou décharger un avion,
c'est plus rapide
avec une grande allée centrale
qu'avec des petites allées.
-Vous vous êtes déjà posé
sur des pistes
qui n'étaient pas des pistes ?
-Oui.
C'est juste
que c'est un peu plus mou.
On a l'impression
d'atterrir moins dur.
-Et c'est moins compliqué ?
-Ca demande un énorme
travail de préparation.
Il faut s'assurer
qu'on a le droit de se poser,
que l'avion va pas s'enfoncer,
qu'on va pas le détruire.
Ca demande un travail en amont
beaucoup plus important.
-C'est magnifique.
On monte pas souvent dans un cockpit
d'avion militaire.
Il y a un pilote qui explique,
donc c'est encore mieux
et on peut se projeter
et se dire :
"Peut-être que plus tard,
je serai dans cet avion."
Ca donne une idée
de ce qu'on veut faire.
-Tu sais quoi tu veux faire ?
-J'hésite entre la chasse
ou le transport
mais je pense
que je vais prendre le transport.
-Pour rejoindre une EAJ,
nul besoin de s'engager
ou d'être issu
d'une famille de militaires.
Il suffit d'être féru d'aéronautique
et ultramotivé
pour déposer sa candidature.
-Priorisez les groupes
où ils sont 3 ou 4.
-A 18 ans,
Manon est l'aînée de l'aventure.
Ce mercredi,
elle encadre les plus jeunes
lors d'une course d'orientation.
Manon a intégré l'EAJ d'Evreux
il y a 3 ans,
sans aucune connaissance
du monde militaire.
Et depuis, la lycéenne porte
un tout autre regard sur l'armée.
-Au début,
c'était très impressionnant.
Ils sont militaires,
ils font peur.
Même d'aller sur base militaire,
ça faisait peur.
Ils vont en guerre,
c'est des personnes importantes.
Elles nous défendent,
elles ont des armes, aussi.
Mais en fait,
on apprend un peu à les connaître.
Il y a vraiment le respect
des encadrants, etc.
-Depuis toujours,
Manon veut devenir avocate.
Mais il y a
quelques mois, grâce à son EAJ,
elle a fait une rencontre
déterminante
pour son projet professionnel.
-J'ai pu rencontrer
l'astronaute Claudie Haigneré,
la première femme française
dans l'espace.
C'est grâce à elle, du coup,
que je sais maintenant
que je m'oriente
vers le droit spatial à l'avenir.
C'est un milieu en pleine expansion,
dont on n'exploite pas encore
toutes les capacités et vraiment,
ça a été une révélation.
Je veux faire du droit spatial.
J'ai pu la recroiser
et lui dire merci.
Grâce à elle,
je sais ce que je veux faire.
-Toutes les semaines,
Alix fait 40 minutes de train
pour rejoindre Evreux
puis grimpe dans le bus
qui l'emmène sur la base aérienne.
Ce collégien vient
de Mantes-la-Jolie.
Avec un père ingénieur aéronautique
et un grand-père colonel,
Alix a baigné dans l'aviation.
En devenant équipier,
il touche son rêve :
devenir pilote de chasse.
Musique dynamique
-Les plus novices
suivent toute l'année
des cours magistraux,
avec en ligne de mire l'obtention
du brevet d'initiation aéronautique.
Au programme, météorologie,
aérodynamisme,
histoire de l'aviation,
sécurité en vol
et anglais aéronautique.
-Tu vas où, Alix ?
-Au centre d'examen
pour le BIA.
-Et comment tu te sens ?
-Ca devrait aller.
Un peu stressé, mais ça ira.
-Pour espérer décrocher son BIA,
Alix doit obtenir
une moyenne de 50 points sur 100.
Pendant 3 heures,
il va plancher
sur des épreuves théoriques.
Un premier pas décisif
dans l'aéronautique.
-Installez-vous là
où l'étiquette porte votre nom.
Musique dynamique
...
-Les téléphones doivent être éteints
et les sacs doivent être à l'avant
ou à l'arrière de la pièce.
Rien à côté de votre table,
s'il vous plaît.
...
-Alors, Alix ?
Comment ça s'est passé ?
-Plutôt bien, j'espère.
Certaines questions,
j'hésite encore,
mais sinon ça s'est très bien passé.
-Toutes les matières ?
-Normalement, toutes les matières.
A part un petit peu navigation,
je suis pas sûr,
mais normalement ouais.
-Aérodrome de Toussus-le-Noble,
dans le département des Yvelines.
L'objectif premier,
c'est, déjà,
vous êtes là pour ça : découverte
de l'avion électrique,
totalement identique
à un avion thermique.
Et comme ça va être quand même
un de vos premiers vols, les EAJ,
ça va être le deuxième objectif,
c'est un vol d'accoutumance,
un vol d'instruction.
Donc vous aurez la totale liberté
de manoeuvrer l'avion au sol,
de décoller l'avion,
de piloter et d'arriver
jusqu'à l'atterrissage.
-Après la théorie, place
à la pratique pour Tom et Alix.
-Il fait pas beau.
-La pluie n'a jamais empêché
un avion de voler.
-En tombant.
-L'orage, oui, mais pas la pluie.
J'allume la radio,
le transpondeur.
Parfait. On est à 520 pieds.
C'est bon...
Donc on va voir
ce qu'on nous dit à la radio.
D'accord ?
-D'accord.
-C'est parti pour 30 minutes
de vol grâce à un partenariat
entre la Fondation Ailes de France
et la Fédération française
d'aéronautique.
Musique dynamique
...
Il est différent d'un avion
à moteur essence,
les sensations sont similaires,
mais pas tellement.
Par exemple, au décollage,
sur un avion essence,
ça fait plus de bruit,
ça vibre plus.
Sur l'avion électrique,
c'est plus calme.
Ca vibre moins, y a moins de bruit,
mais quand même,
l'excitation est quand même là,
reste présente.
C'est extraordinaire de voler.
Donc oui, très content
à la fin du vol et bons souvenirs.
-Ce jour-là, Alix a pris
les commandes pour la première fois.
-Comment ça s'est passé ?
Il s'est bien débrouillé ?
-Très bien.
Il a piloté du début à la fin.
Il a décollé l'avion,
il a roulé l'avion au sol,
il a décollé l'avion,
il a piloté ensuite l'avion
et il s'est même posé également,
donc un bon futur pilote.
-Ouf !
-Tu serais bien resté là-haut ?
-Oui !
-On leur inculque
les valeurs de l'aviateur.
Quatre valeurs phares :
le respect, l'intégrité,
le service et l'excellence.
Les quatre lettres
font le mot "rise".
Le mot "rise", en anglais,
c'est s'élever,
c'est à la fois s'élever,
m'éduquer,
mais c'est aussi décoller,
comme un avion.
Donc il y a une symbolique derrière
qui est intéressante.
Et c'est aussi leur apprendre
les valeurs de l'aéronautique,
découvrir le monde
de l'aéronautique,
de la vie en communauté.
-Et quoi de mieux que le sport
pour forger le sens du collectif ?
A Saintes, les équipiers
sont en pleine séance de frisbee.
Pour le week-end de l'Ascension,
13 EAJ sont réunis
pour un challenge national.
Pendant trois jours,
Alix et ses camarades
vont s'affronter
sur la base aérienne 722, fief
de l'école d'enseignement technique
de l'Armée de l'air et de l'espace.
-Les jeunes des EAJ
ont généralement entre 13 et 17 ans.
Nos élèves ont entre 16 et 18 ans.
Nos élèves, ce sont de jeunes
militaires qui s'engagent
mais qui sont militaires
et qui sont lycéens,
en première et terminale,
et les EAJ, ce sont quelque part
leur pendant civil
mais déjà lié
avec l'Armée de l'air et de l'espace
et avec le monde de l'aéronautique.
Donc finalement
c'est un croisement des cultures
entre des gens
qui sont déjà engagés
et d'autres
dans une démarche associative.
-A travers la pratique sportive,
les équipiers apprennent
la cohésion
et le dépassement de soi,
deux valeurs phares
de l'identité militaire.
Ce samedi, les jeunes participent
à un laser run,
un dérivé du biathlon
qui mêle course à pied
et tir à la carabine,
et Alix a bien l'intention
de se surpasser
pour faire gagner son équipe.
Musique dynamique
...
-Voilà, c'est ça !
C'est bien.
C'est bien, c'est bien.
...
-Eprouvant !
C'est du cardio.
Faut bien retenir son souffle,
pour la carabine.
J'ai fait aucune erreur,
sinon, c'était des tours en plus,
mais je suis essoufflé.
-Des efforts récompensés.
Les jaunes occuperont
la 3e marche du podium.
-2, 1, 2. 2. 2. 2.
-Ce matin, rendez-vous à 8h
sur la place d'armes
pour la levée des couleurs.
En immersion, ces jeunes civils
touchent de près aux traditions
et aux coutumes propres aux armées,
à commencer par la coiffe
réglementaire,
un calot couleur bleu nuit.
-Pour l'ensemble,
à mon commandement...
-De quoi nourrir
un sentiment d'appartenance
à la communauté des aviateurs.
-Allons enfants
-DE LA PATRIE
LE JOUR DE GLOIRE EST ARRIVE
CONTRE NOUS DE LA TYRANNIE
L'ETENDARD SANGLANT EST LEVE
-C'est un beau moment ?
-Très bien, très bien.
On a un petit peu l'habitude,
on les a formés pour ça aussi.
Non, toujours très solennel.
Des moments émouvants,
et toujours la fierté, aussi.
Le lever des couleurs, voilà.
On sait pourquoi on est là.
-Allez. Trois, deux, un...
Souriez !
-Le 14 juillet,
Manon et Tom appliqueront
ce code de bonne conduite
sur les Champs-Elysées.
-Il y aura
divers représentants de l'Etat, etc.
Donc, ça fait un petit peu peur.
Mais beaucoup de fierté,
quand même,
de se dire que j'ai pu en arriver là
grâce aux Escadrilles Air Jeunesses,
et ça me fait...
C'est...
un grand...
Comment dire ?
C'est une grande responsabilité
qu'on nous donne.
Mais je suis vraiment très contente
de participer à ça.
C'est un honneur, vraiment,
de participer au 14 juillet.
-Il est tout juste
six heures.
Musique militaire
Nous retrouvons Manon et Tom
pour une répétition
en conditions réelles,
sur la place de la Concorde.
-Quand j'annonce votre numéro,
venez vous faire équiper.
-Cette année, les EAJ participent
à l'animation finale du défilé.
Pour ce cru 2023,
la Résistance est mise à l'honneur,
à l'occasion des 80 ans
du Conseil national
de la Résistance.
-C'est le coussin de la Résistance
du groupe de bombardement Bretagne.
C'était un groupe
d'aviateurs résistants,
qui ont aidé à libérer la France
et se sont battus en Afrique.
-Le 14 juillet, Manon présentera
la décoration de ces bombardiers
devant la tribune présidentielle,
aux côtés
de 150 jeunes.
Tous chanteront la Marseillaise,
avec le choeur
de l'armée française.
-AUX ARMES CITOYENS
FORMEZ VOS BATAILLONS
-C'est génial, on sent,
quand on passe, au milieu
de la musique,
on est envahi par cette émotion.
C'est incroyable.
Et de représenter le coussin
qu'on porte,
c'est très fort.
C'est une grande chance,
car je suis la seule à représenter
l'armée de l'air,
et la seule
Escadrille Air Jeunesse
à porter le coussin.
C'est un honneur.
C'est la cerise sur le gâteau
pour toutes mes années d'EAJ.
Musique rap
-Lycée militaire de Saint-Cyr.
Cinq heures du matin.
Le défilé a lieu
aujourd'hui.
Il ne reste plus que quelques heures
à Manon pour se préparer.
Cléo vient
lui prêter main-forte
pour former
le chignon parfait.
-Je te laisse ajuster, au niveau
de la hauteur et du serrage.
-Oui. Après, il faut plaquer.
-Oui.
-Mets la dose,
il faut pas avoir peur.
-T'inquiète,
je vais mettre la dose.
-Alors, Manon,
c'est le grand jour ?
-Oui. C'est stressant.
On est un peu dans le rush.
Mais ça va bien se passer.
C'est ce qu'il faut se dire !
-Concentration de rigueur,
pour Manon et ses camarades,
et dernière mise au point
avant d'entrer en scène.
-Simplement une petite revue.
Alors. Donc, le calot, c'est bon.
L'insigne...
Je vérifie.
Bien.
On va le redresser
un petit peu.
Voilà.
Je vais me permettre aussi.
Parfait. On regarde.
Parfait.
On s'est préparés
depuis plus d'une semaine,
à se réveiller aux aurores.
Le grand jour est arrivé.
Vous avez fait ces répétitions
avec sérieux, avec grande rigueur.
Je vous félicite. On est fiers
de ce que vous avez pu accomplir.
-On est vraiment
stressés,
mais c'est vrai qu'on se dit
que rien ne peut nous perturber,
car on est vraiment calés.
Musique rap
C'est parti. On se retrouve
sur les Champs-Elysées.
...
-ET LA TRACE
DE LEURS VERTUS
BIEN MOINS JALOUX
DE LEUR SURVIVRE
QUE DE
PARTAGER LEUR CERCUEIL
-La soif d'apprendre
chevillée au corps,
ils représentent une jeunesse
volontaire et passionnée.
Tous sortiront grandis
de cette expérience.
-AUX ARMES CITOYENS
-Elle m'a fait
grandir,
elle m'a fait plus...
on va dire pas forgé,
mais changer d'esprit,
avec le respect,
la cohésion, la discipline.
Tout ça, ça m'a fait évoluer,
depuis un an.
-J'ai découvert plein de gens.
Plein de gens.
J'ai fait
des bonnes rencontres.
Et puis, c'est tout le côté
passionnant. C'est passionnant.
-On fait des choses
que pas tout le monde peut faire.
On voit des choses
que tout le monde voit pas.
Après, c'est magique.
On peut dire que c'est magique.
Extraordinaire, encore.
-Etre tous ensemble,
ne pas avoir peur des autres,
avoir un fort esprit d'équipe,
c'est vraiment les racines des EAJ,
on va dire.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...